gun making and selling is a huge
business in America and even as the u.s.
faces its worst economy since the Great
Depression gun and ammunition sales are
up eight percent many lawfully bought
guns and up on a black market via theft
or even legal purchases from dealers but
how you get a gun is different in almost
every state California has the toughest
gun laws with a background check 10-day
waiting period and mandatory gun safety
tests in Virginia where Casey lives if
she can pass a background check she's
allowed one new handgun a month in Texas
you can buy as many guns per day as you
can afford and concealed weapons can be
carried in 35 states
drop it in your pocket guns in it's an
easy carry you drop it into your pocket
put your hands in your pocket you need a
gun you lift makes for a good day
remember eyes this is it
349 I like the rounded feel about Scott
place your fingers got the texture and I
like I like the color to it's kind of
cute yeah so that's kind of fun you know
it seems like gun people are not that
different from regular people shocking I
know so that's been good to know and
it's you know it's just kind of like
shopping for anything else it seems like
it's not that different think the main
thing that I keep hearing over and over
is that I just need to try shooting a
gun from myself and see what feels good
what I'm comfortable with these ones are
pretty Casey remains ambivalent about
buying a gun even with the fear of the
break-in still vivid she's unclear if
she will become a part of the gun nation